[Musique]
dans les jours précédant l'invasion
russe de jeudi matin et les observateurs
et des journalistes qui observe les
médias sociaux russes on
révélé certains éléments de des
informations qui proviennent d'éléments
pro russe et qui tendent cherché à
justifier une invasion russe d'une
crainte donc je donne quelques exemples
de choses qui ont circulé dans les
réseaux sociaux juste on commence avec
cette vidéo le qui a été diffusé le 21
février par les autorités de la
république populaire donetsk qui est née
une région de l'ukraine contrôlés par
des séparatistes province on voit un
homme semble avoir été amputé par un
obus selon eux lancé par les forces
iraniennes le problème c'est que l'homme
en question on voit que la rendant la
vidéo qu'il avait déjà une prothèse donc
il était amputée avant que cette
supposée attaque a eu lieu donc c'est
clairement mise en scène on a cette
autre vidéo là qui a été diffusé le 18
février par des miliciens armés
de donner vie que ce sont des saboteurs
qui s'apprêtait à lancer une attaque
contre une usine de chlore dans la ville
de leurs neuf cas
ils ont diffusé la vidéo sur télégramme
en disant que ça s'est passé ce jour là
il ya un problème c'est que sur
télégramme on peut le voir les
métadonnées des vidéos qui sont publiées
et en observant les métadonnées cette
vidéo là on peut voir clairement que la
vidéo a été filmée le 4 février et non
le 18 février donc encore une fois une
vidéo qui ne correspond pas du tout à la
réalité et puis il ya cette vidéo là qui
a été diffusée par certains médias
russes dont la première chaîne russe on
montre un char blindé qui appartiendrait
aux forces kényanes qui a été détruite
par les forces us après avoir pénétré
dans le territoire russe il ya un autre
problème avec les vidéos là c'est que le
char en question c'est un char du modèle
btr 70ème qui selon des analystes
militaires et en charge jusque là les
forces du craignait n'utilise clairement
pas donc
il ya quelque chose qui ne fonctionne
pas loin on voit dans quel sens de les
vidéos en question vont je pense qu'on a
convié ses affaires je suis une évasion
de l'ukraine c'est une tactique sont
bien connus je sais pas quel point ç'a
fonctionné pour convaincre la communauté
internationale parce qu' énormément de
scepticisme envahit au revoir les
services d'information us de la part de
l'occident donc clairement ça n'a pas
convaincu le reste de la planète parce
que ça a convaincu les reçus même on le
voit déjà ou non aux paroles ya des
manifestations dans les vues dans
certaines villes en russie pour dire non
à la garde donc potentiellement que sait
faire fonctionner en vue sinon plus je
tiendrai à avertir la population pouvoir
extrêmement extrêmement tension sur les
réseaux sociaux dans une période comme
la nôtre il va avoir des vidéos dont des
images qui vont circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux on va voir des explosions des
corps des gens se tirer dessus des
avions chasseurs lancé des bombes des
choses comme ça faut faire vraiment
vraiment attention de ne pas rajouter à
ceux qui roulent en partageant des
images ou des vidéos qui sont ou des
informations qui sont non vérifie donc
j'appelle vraiment la population par
extrêmement attention de partage de
richesse des sources les sources fiables
par rapport se confient leur parce qu'on
s'en sorte c'est en partageant n'importe
quoi dans une situation qui est tous si
volatil et dangereuse que celle là
[Musique]